it's your boy Shakur Stevenson and I'm
here on the bootleg Cav podcast check me
out let's do
it hey yo boot Lake cev show man we got
a special guest in here one of the
baddest men on the planet Shakur
Stevenson is in the building welcome sir
yes sir yes sir Jersey's finest is here
what's going on how you doing bro [__]
I'm I'm good I'm chilling uh couple of
weeks away from the fight um I'm ready
to put on the show yeah I was going to
say man cuz like you've had fights fall
through obviously this fight is November
16th right yeah this fight is November
16th y Edwin De Santos yep um first of
all uh I'm curious like you feeling good
cuz I know like training heading into
the fight we always you know watch uh I
always watched like when Showtime would
have the you know the the pay-per-views
and you'd be able to watch the behind
the scenes of the fight so I know that
it's it's different now you can't really
get to see everything but um yeah I I
feel great I'm uh fine uh honestly I
think this the best I've been feeling um
getting ready for a fight so uh I I'm
I'm ready how intense is like the
sparring sessions for you
like prior to the fight like do you ramp
up or do you like kind of chill out a
little bit to kind of preserve what you
know I I'm I'm so competitive like I'll
be having like issues so like in Spar
I'm more so like the person I like to go
a lot of rounds um you could throw two
three people in the ring with me I I
want to keep going but um my coaches
kind of gota like pull me back and are
you so competitive that if someone Nails
you in sparring you want to like get get
get your get back hell yeah if somebody
land a good shot I tell them like good
shot we got to run it back though yeah
I'm not getting out the ring until I get
mine so we got to run it back uh we got
to do another round um I make somebody
stay in there for rounds and rounds
until they say I'm done yo for me uh
being somebody who is a fat [__] uh
respectfully of course to all the fat
[__] out there I always I always am
curious cuz you guys are so good at
dropping weight you guys have figured
out weight loss in a way that most obese
men in the world have not figured out
all right how do you drop like what
first of all cuz I've seen guys drop
like uh like like wild amounts of weight
pretty quickly like what is the key if
you need to make weight and maybe you
you've been [__] up the wrong food
the last week or so how do you drop
weight so fast as a boxer I think that
um it all got to do with discipline I
think discipline is like the main thing
um I mean that's obvious but that would
be you know that's drinking water
drinking water drinking water is like a
huge thing when you want to cut weight
on do you go into like a sauna and just
sweat it out nah I don't do the sauna
but people do that do that people that
do the sauna but me I I don't believe in
the son I think that like I I don't like
it I don't like the way it make me feel
after I'll be feeling like kind of drain
but I drink water um and work out work
out you got to put extra layer of
clothes on too that was not the easy
answer we were hoping for drink water
and work out everybody yeah but you got
to drink a lot of water it's not just
drink uh two glasses no you got to drink
like see I got this gallon thing right
here yeah you stay you're staying with
the water you drink a gallon a day or
more I drink over a gallon a day wow
yeah that's a lot of water you must have
to piss a lot ooh definitely do I'll be
waking up in the middle of the night um
having P to is it true like obviously
your fight's a couple of weeks away are
you withstanding from busted nuts at
this point yes you're not beating cheeks
nah hell no for sure how how far out do
you like cut off the the the you know
the the the Intercourse I think I'm like
a four we typ person wow good for you
man I don't know how like certain people
be saying like I've done it before yeah
eight weeks eight weeks they do eight
weeks strong um shout out to them them
people they tough and do you like feel
the difference cuz you I have heard like
you know like it's like an energy thing
like yeah I feel I feel a difference I I
feel like when I bust I feel like it
make me a little lazy like I'll be in
the ring lazy smart man yeah but when I
like hold it it's like I'm not as lazy
I'm feeling good and can do what I want
I got to get your thoughts uh there was
a big fight that happened this past
weekend um what are your thoughts on the
uh the f
uh fight oh my God man did he steal that
one man I don't know what I was watching
I you watched it yeah I seen some of it
cuz I was sparring at the same time got
you so then I got done and I watched
like the last four rounds but I want to
say I don't know I don't know what I was
watching like I don't know what Tyson
Fury was doing it didn't make sense to
me it didn't look like Tyson Fury in the
ring like it didn't but he still won but
cuz it was a was it a draw it was a draw
right right but no it was he won he won
he end okay okay but it didn't look like
him like I I watched plenty of Tyson FY
fights and uh usually he's punching it
didn't look like he was even throwing
punches he was doing a lot of hugging he
wasn't punching it didn't make sense to
me like it it didn't he didn't look like
the same person to me I wonder like cuz
you always see like I haven't seen so
many people say someone was robbed so
much in a long time like I remember
there was um maybe like a Pacquiao fight
like 10 or 15 years ago that I remember
it was there was a lot of back backlash
on uh when I was living in Vegas but it
seems like the consensus is that this
guy was robbed man any close fight they
going to say It's a Robbery yeah so it
don't matter like just because he's like
a MMA person and they they suspect Tyson
F to just wash him um if it's close of
course they G to say It's a Robbery so I
don't I I ain't watched The First
beginning rounds to really tell you um
but I all I'm going say is I
it just seemed like they want that to be
like the narrative so well I mean look
at the end of the day like that that is
something that a lot of people say about
boxing is that they feel like because it
always goes to scorecards that it there
is room for people to get robbed you
know what I'm saying like and from a
Fan's perspective you know what I mean
I'm I'm sure it can be frustrating to be
like yo there some bad judges there's
some bad judges out there right and then
there's rematches that people want to
have made and all this [__] right so I I
don't mean to cut you off before you ask
your question but I want to say um any
MMA fighters who uh feel this though
that they can jump in the boxing ring
with a box anybody close to my weight I
would love for y'all to jump in the ring
with me and uh try me out Conor McGregor
try me out any of them I don't care
which one it is uh um Cody Crawley
what's the people that's like there's
the guy who's like the Maga dude who's
fighting this weekend uh Cody kington I
think yeah whatever what whatever
whoever it is um that's close to my way
I would love for them to get a r trop me
out well it's crazy cuz the nana new
dude like he like he held his own like I
was expecting him to get smoked for sure
and that's why I would love to show like
it ain't going to go the same when I get
in there I would love to show like no
MMA fighter could get in the ring with
me and even survive have you had anybody
approach you to do anything like that
cuz it seems like that's kind of the the
thing going right now I heard it was
somebody said that um one of the guys
said my name um what's the guy he be
going back and forth with Devin too um I
don't know his name I don't know his
name but uh like I said any one of them
dudes when to step in the ring I feel it
feels like easy money for you it is for
sure but I just want to show them like
you can't jump in no boxing ring with me
and it's going to go that way I promise
you I'm not going to lie that that yeah
I was a little surprised to see that
that fight went the way it went cuz yeah
I ain't like it I was like damn that's
going to open up the the the can of
worms for everybody to want to come in I
felt like it it was
disrespectful um yo so this is the fight
that uh we're we're getting obviously uh
there's been a lot of I mean everybody's
asked you about obviously whenever
you're going to fight Haney is this
going to happen after this fight is
there any sort of progression in those
talks cuz I think we keep hearing about
the negotiations falling through maybe
he's not serious about fighting you what
what is is is that fight ever going to
get made I would love for the fight to
happen um [__] I y'all can clearly see
that I want the fight yeah like y'all
can clearly see I don't know why like
people try to spin the narratives and
like a lot of people good at social
media so they'll turn the narrative into
something else and 30 other people run
with that narrative but um truth be told
I love to fight like I I I fight anybody
yeah um I jumped in the ring with him
for a reason I didn't just jump in the
ring and do that for no other reason
besides okay let's get let's get the
fight started
and and is the is what's off about it
still the split I think what's off about
it is his team like I don't think I
think his team is going to throw
anything out there to uh make sure the
fight don't happen um I don't think that
they want the fight to happen right now
um that's what I heard like from what I
was hearing I'm I'm hearing that well
that's what it feels like there's so
many weird politics in boxing that I
don't think people understand if you're
just like a generic boxing fan cuz
you're like well this should be easy
like this guy and this guy they a fight
this is a big money fight there's a lot
of money to be made but sometimes like
you said there's timing yeah it's
business and that's that's above
everything and that's how they looking
at it they see it as okay why we fight
this big RIS fighter right now rather
than wait a couple of years where we we
could make more money but yeah they
could run it cuz if they lose to you
that's going to [__] up that that might
[__] up his bag yeah and then like like
like you know it's it's almost like what
happened with um for people who are like
casual boxing fans fans it's like Jake
Paul losing is bad for business yes
right so he has to keep winning so the
fact that he lost to Ty or Tommy Fury is
is is uh was was kind of bad for
business yeah but like I say him and
that one dude well his his brother in
that one dude of they they stirred up
some [__] and that fight was terrible my
only issue with it right yeah if that's
the case don't perpetrate as if you're
you're that's what you want to do you
know you're perpetrating and acting like
that um this is what you want and um you
talking big but truth be told um you put
me and him in a in a ring where nobody
else can help him there's nobody else
that going to be able to fight for him
what's going to happen like he know deep
down inside that I'm the truth that's
what he know he know he done been the
ring with me several times um he go ask
him like really ask him and tell him to
be honest about me as a fighter um
you'll really hear how he talk and um
honestly I think he's a good fighter but
um I think that his
levels um I just saw uh J Prince was uh
out in the Saudi Arabia with Vince
McMahon and Kanye at the fight what's
your relationship these days like with J
Prince oh that's my guy that's my guy uh
like I said um in other interviews I
appreciate him I appreciate everything
that he done for me um he's he he's
family to me so um I I got nothing but
good things to say about Jay uh I
appreciate them yeah when you go to
Houston are you just like do you get the
red carpet yeah for sure you go to htown
yeah have you been to Onyx out there
Onyx uh good place I don't know
establishment there I don't remember if
I've been there or not I was just there
a few days ago we uh we went hog hunting
hog hunting yeah with this rapper
there's a rapper out there named Mexican
OT and he took us hog hunting in a
helicopter we were like hanging out the
side of a the helicopter bro I swear to
God we were hanging out the side of a
helicopter
with AR-15 shooting
pigs by the way they're Pest and they're
invasive species so my mind I felt like
I was you know helping helping Farmers
out you know what I'm saying n i I've
done it before but you've done that not
in no helicopter but you killed the pigs
no I shot at him I ain't I a a hit
nothing n a but you did it in Texas yeah
oh so you did you did what did you have
the night vision goggles yeah oh yeah so
yeah we did that too yeah yeah for sure
you sure you didn't hit nothing n I'm
sure I Ain hit nothing bro you had the
goggles you got the scope I'm sure I
didn't hit that you missed on purpose
you're a good man nah it was like a uh
they was farther down I smoked them it
wasn't uh as close yeah no it was fun it
was like I felt like I was in like with
the night goggles at cuz we did the
helicopter and then we did the nighttime
[__] I felt like I was in Call of Duty
and then they were near some cows and
they were like you know they could kill
those cows I was like not yet cuz I'mma
kill them first they save some Cattle
Man this dude crazy uh um yo um y talk
obviously you're real tight with bud
with Terence Crawford
um how you feeling about a rematch
between him and
Spence uh my honest opinion on it um I
think that Errol is a great fighter I
think that um he's tough and and he got
the Heart of a Lion for even wanting to
do a rematch with but but um my honest
opinion I don't want to see it like I
wouldn't want to why the first fight was
so like definitive yeah that it was like
it be you know it wasn't like it was
just too one-sided exactly yeah like if
it was more so like a competitive fight
then it'll be like okay ID like to see
it but it wasn't like competitive enough
for me to like want to watch it again
but that's just my opinion on it I don't
want nobody take it the wrong way but um
I don't want to see it so you're
fighting uh Edwin de los Santos yes um I
don't know who the hell this guy is so
I'm assuming that you're going to beat
the living [__] out of this guy yeah n
but he's he's a good fighter I'm going
to put it out there and say U I watched
him uh he got good boxing skills um you
got to respect your opponent at all
times man no no he's a good fighter
though no I'm saying but you have to
like I feel like sometimes we see our
like boxers popping [__] in press
conferences and I'm like yo man like
this guy's still professional there's a
reason why he's fighting you so this
guy's good what I'm saying is you just
got to be aware of who you're in the
ring with sometimes and being aware of
that you don't want to sleep on nobody
uh sleeping on that dude would be like
the wrong move for me to make so um this
dude is a great boxer puncher and um you
could tell that he's hungry and he's
going to come to win so uh for sure I I
respect him as a a fighter but he's just
going against the best he's going
against the best and I'm sure all the
money in Vegas is on you so yeah for
sure yeah I always wonder cuz you know I
used to live in Vegas and betting on
fights was so much fun do you ever like
think to yourself like if I lose people
are eating [__] at the sports book hell
no n I ain't thinking like that um I'm
tip fighter I'll be so confident that
I'll go bet on myself oh that is that
allowed uh I mean if you do it the right
way yeah Floyd used to do that yeah I
don't I don't know I think I don't know
uh can you go to the casinos and do it
but I can one time I interviewed 50 set
when I was living in Vegas and Floyd was
fighting that weekend and 50 had a
million dollars in a backpack he brought
it to the radio station he's like I'm
about to take this across the street put
on Floyd I said damn he's like for Floyd
but I I I did that and I lost before cuz
I had bet on a um knockout and one you
lost money on yourself man I lost like
uh I want to say 15,000 of my so you bet
you were going to knock him out yes cuz
it was it was a fight that they didn't
think I was going to knock him out which
fight was this it was um against Robson
CU and that's why the whole fight like
my coaches like they telling me like
chill chill chill the whole fight in
your head you're like I got to win this
money I'm about to knock this
[__] out that's all I was
thinking of like I'm trying to get the
knock out but they telling me like yo
just box your way into it I'm like no
forget what y'all talking about lay him
out I'm going to get him like we're
about to take yeah what you know what
the what the payout would have been cuz
I'm sure the odds had to be positive uh
I don't remember what the payout was but
I know I bet like 15 bands on me
stopping that dude before like the ninth
round that's so F and I was so mad that
I didn't yo I love that dude um in your
opinion man um removing yourself from
the equation who you think right now is
the best pound-for-pound fighter best
pound-for-pound fighter yeah Terence
Crawford it ain't even no no question
about it it ain't nothing to think about
um Terence been dominating the sport for
years uh Canelo is a great fighter but
we done seen him lose on several
occasions and um we still haven't seen
nobody crack the cold on how to beat
Terence Crawford so um something in that
Nebraska water you know what I'm saying
yo we got to stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie desk
right man it is betting season right now
we got football we got basketball NBA is
underway that boy wean is looking crazy
put all your money on him to win Rookie
of the Year all right do it at my bookie
right now go to my bookie all right when
you sign up at my bookie use the promo
code bootle use that promo code right
now and you're going to get a no
strings cash bonus that's right put your
deposit in withdraw the free cash up to
$200 right away I mean even if you don't
want to bet create an account get an
extra $200 take it out keep it moving
all right but look right now football
season is getting into the thick of it
all right I feel like the playoff
picture is going to start to really kind
of become a lot more clear soon all
right yo shout out to the Bengals
Bengals is finally getting it together
my Cardinals look like absolute dog [__]
which is what I love nonetheless you can
bet every single weekend on my bookie
this is what's up about my bookie you
can do your daily odds boost your same
game parlays and the crazy huge prize
pool contest use that promo code right
now on your first deposit so when you
sign up with a new account your very
first deposit use the promo code bootleg
this is important because you're going
to get up to $200 in cash when you use
that promo code bootleg claim your cash
bonus right now no strings attached
deposit withdraw quick there's so much
going on man try the my bookie money bag
to grab a potential Super Bro front
runner at Long Shot odds plus 38,000 on
the Eagles and Chiefs man is crazy you
can bet anything anytime anywhere they
got the full service casino going down
slots roulette whatever it is if you're
into it you can gamble it you can bet it
my bookie sign up with that promo code
boot leg right now also got to give a
big shout out to the homies at my well I
already said my bookie [__] new
commercial shout out to the homies over
at blueo man that's right blue everybody
always ask me does blue Chu work
well you don't take my word for it try
it for free for a month by using that
promo code bootleg right now blue has
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Calis uh it's all wrapped up into a
blue chewable form delivered right to
your doorstep in discret packaging no
doctor's
appointments uh are needed all right you
don't have to go into the doctor
everything's online go to blue.com all
right sign up with that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free if
your dick ain't [__] it's time to get
a [__] again you know what I mean
you're dealing with a little rectile
dysfunction maybe a little anxiety at
work maybe you're stressed out maybe
you're just married to someone you're
tired of [__] let's be honest
sometimes you need a little extra you
know a little extra some some to get you
over the Finish Line get that blue chw
baby blue chew try the first month for
free they're going to give it to you for
free a month supply for free
go to blue.com use the promo code
bootleg right now thank me later let's
get back to the interview I don't even
know have you been in Nebraska with him
yeah I've been to Nebraska with him
what's it like there like I'm just
curious where like like you see this guy
training in Nebraska and you're he's
like the only thing out of Nebraska you
know what I'm he really like when he do
his camps he do it in Colorado oh word
yeah he don't even that high elevation
yeah yeah but uh now I've been there
with him I just think bud just different
like I don't even know if it's Nebraska
I don't know what it is I think buz is
just a different individual as a whole
um just being around him the dude can do
everything like there is nothing bu
Crawford can't do like I done testing
him out in so many different things like
all right come on let's play this let's
do this let's do that and he'll be good
at every single thing and beat a lot of
people at a lot of things so um um
Terence cord is definitely um top level
in um in everything that he do um after
this fight assuming everything goes well
you win um are you already eyeing who
you I mean obviously there's fans that
throw names out like tank Davis and
lenko is there anybody who you got in
your sights I was supposed to be
fighting lenko for this fight lenko
turned me down
so yeah I keep him on the list but it's
like uh is he going to fight me it's
almost like which fight is like fight
like like what fight can you actually
put together which fighter is willing to
get in ring with me that's the what it
really comes down to um what I really
think that they're trying to do they're
hoping to see like a wrinkle they're
hoping to see like okay chinking your
armor almost yeah they want to see okay
oh that's how we could that's how we
could beat them yeah yeah and that's
when they'll be brave enough to jump in
the ring but as of right now they they
they haven't seen no wrinkles so it's
kind of yo the boxing game is so
frustrating bro like if if if these
promoters would just do give the fans
what they want more people would watch
but it's not just the promoters the
promoters can try it's the fighters too
if the fighter don't want to fight or
they like oh that's not enough money or
they come up with a thousand different
excuses on why not to fight um hey can't
do nothing about it um for you uh if you
we were just talking about little Wayne
you were bumping some little Wayne when
I walked in off your phone yeah who's
like your Mount Rushmore hip hop who's
your who's your top four or five all
time man all time all time and then give
me right now too like cuz that's two
different lists I think yeah definitely
two different list uh Tupac CH toac
biggie
Jay-z Eminem a little Wayne I respect
that yeah that's a pretty good I mean
that's that's that's kind of like the
four or five yeah for sure
and uh right now I'm might have to go
with little
baby right now right now
I don't know it's kind of it's kind of
different it's rough right now little
baby uh young boy
Dirk oh young boy and
Dirk nice Rod wave Rod wave is so fire
yeah yeah right we being like like do
you do you tap in with any of the Jersey
[__] going on in or the um the drill
[__] going on in like New York cuz like
obviously you're you're from Jersey but
like there's like this whole drill scene
that's moving out of New York just kind
of crazy I don't know how tapped in you
are with it n i I'll be I'll be minding
my business but um I I see some of the
uh artists coming up um I see what's
going on so uh I respect and like right
I mean you I'm sure you see like now
like the Philly club uh Jersey Club
music thing is starting to pop like
people are doing that [__] and it's like
this [__] has been going on forever I'm
about to say the Jersey Club been going
on since I was a little but it's crazy
cuz now people are like kind of like
doing their own version of it yeah and
making it to like like the b Shake
something you know what I'm saying like
these are like these are like these are
this is club music yeah facts facts um n
i uh I be tun thing but like I said I
don't I'll be out of the way too 100%
man um for you man talk about this this
upcoming fight obviously uh you know
it's it's a fight that fans just want to
see you fight you got fans but um for
you uh if I have let's say cuz I'm a I'm
a degenerate Gambler shout out to my
bookie go to my bookie use a promo code
bootleg you know what I'm saying I'm
trying to get in on some action am I
betting The Knockout what round am I
betting like what are we doing here is
there give me some give me some
consultation I got the man right here
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah n i
uh like I said when I lost money on
myself I kind of uh bagged up a little
bit from uh trying to predict what's
going to happen but I'm betting the
knock
out it's a possibility I don't put it
past uh myself but um we got to see what
happens when we get in the ring um I
can't go in there looking for it I got
to just box and um if it comes it comes
I wonder your thoughts man with Showtime
like leaving the boxing world as
important as they've been for so many
years for boxing uh what do you think
that means for the
sport I mean just mean maybe a new
outlet is on the way um I don't think
that just cuz show time
left that um them guys over there with
uh PBC and Al Heyman they going to need
a Outlet to fight on and uh I think that
they going to find something big and
some major where uh you can get guys um
like tank and um Errol
Spence um all them type dudes uh in the
ring on a big
platform yo I wonder you you I'm sure
you saw the Fallout that Ryan Garcia had
with Oscar De La Hoya right after he
seem like they fall out every week
though it's a lot it's a lot to say the
least but it feels like in boxing like
your immediate team is like extremely
important right like you got to trust
who's in your corner you got to trust
who who's with you all the time we've
seen so many situations kind of play out
like when you see like cuz I feel like
it is kind of like a predator sport but
like for you how do you make sure like
you kind of keep your team super like
locked in and when you see something
like that like if I mean it almost feels
like that that situation kind of like
ripped the spirit from that kid for a
while you know what I'm saying I think I
think um with with situations like that
uh I just think with your team you just
got to build trust like you be able to
trust your team and know that they going
to make um know that they going to come
to you by the decisions but also have
like the right decisions to make and um
with my team I think I got a great team
with uh J Prince and um Josh duin I
think that they've been doing a great
job throughout my career um far as every
in every situation uh they always
deliver so um like I said I trust my
team I ain't got no issues with my team
I can't sit here and complain about my
team we've been doing it big and uh it's
getting even bigger now for sure for
sure um do you feel like this YouTube
shit's finally over with cuz I feel like
that last pay-per-view with Dylan dannis
and the KSI dude and and Logan Paul was
so it was so terrible man I think that
they got to like if they going to do it
I think that they should start letting
them fight some boxers too just show
them like okay well cuz the only boxer
that they fought has beat him right the
the fury dude and he's kind of like a
he's kind of like a fake boxer yeah I
was about to say I never really heard of
him until he's just he's just the he's
just the guy's brother I never heard of
Tommy Fury until like YouTube like I
never really heard of him so do you feel
like it's a good cuz like at the end of
the day it's more eyes on the sport and
there are undercard fights you know what
I'm saying like do you feel like it's a
good thing some of the attention that
like Jake Paul's bringing to the sport
or do you feel like it's kind of you
know I think it's a good thing I just
like I said I would rather see them jump
in the ring with an actual boxer before
they sit there and keep calling out
boxers like I done heard several
YouTubers get out there and say oh I
want to fight uh tank Davis I want to
fight Shakur St I want to fight Deon
Haney and if y'all saying that come on
well they show show let's show them like
the difference between getting in there
with a YouTuber and getting in there
with somebody who been boxing their
entire life
like it's just funny to me cuz if y'all
say my name I would love to who said
your name I don't heard uh what was it
uh Dean Dean something something like
that Dean the great uh I don't know dude
yeah I it ain't like Jake Paul I'm not
under the YouTube world like that I just
be like oh Jake Paul's fighting let me
see if he's going to get his ass beat
finally all right man also want to give
a shout out to our family over at kingp
baby you already know man we always stay
King pomed up over here it's the only
thing we're smoking you know what I love
love about King pom so many
flavors so natural organic tobacc free
leaves this is how we're smoking at the
bootleg Kev podcast and um like let me
just say this dude like all shapes and
sizes you know what I mean like let give
you a little variation of the type of
King poms you can get down with you know
just different shapes different sizes
natural organic tobacc free a clean
smoke if you will so many the this is
the honey berry which might be my new
favorite I do love the uh the energy
drink one the red rain is fire all right
um but listen if you want to get down
with some of these King Palms trust me
when I say man they are the best way to
smoke um first of all you can go to your
local liquor store 7-Eleven all that
they got King poms all right so go pick
something up or you can go to their
website now if you go to their website
King pom.com go to King pom.com use the
promo code bootle right now and uh you
can say 50% off at King pom.com half off
whatever you want
what are we
smoking this is the uh the Orange Swirl
what's dope about King pom is they have
like the flavor the tpine infused tips
so like let's say you got this one right
you got some of that Orange Swirl you
feel
me you load it up put your wheat in
there or whatever your
tobacco and then in the tip you press
down on that thing and you you're
getting hit with all that
flavor all right so go to uh King
pom.com use the promo code bootleg right
now get half off or just go to your
local liquor store go to your local
7-Eleven and run it up with some King
Pals also want to give a shout out to
our family at odd Sox man don't forget
get you some odd Soxs in your life go to
oddsocks official.com right now holiday
season's coming they make great gifts
man we can do so much they got the ET
you know I mean they got the draws if
youall a know odd Soxs making underwear
now and they're more comfortable than
all the other underwear Brands let me be
honest with you all right they got all
the licenses how about Top Ramen
underwear let me just take a peek of
these bad
boys see what we got here the ramen
draws baby what how about some Mountain
Dew Code Red Socks or or you know what
how about this how about we we keep the
soda theme going we got Mountain Dew
Baja Blast oh wait wait wait wait wait
we we we don't want either of those
we'll keep the soda them going what
about some orange crush socks what if
you're fat like me you like chocolate
Hershey's they got WWE Breaking Bad
Godfather good I mean just all of the
damn things Power Rangers all the crazy
licenses go to oddsock official.com use
the promo code bootleg right now and you
will save 20% off odd Sox official.com
promo code bootleg save 20% off your
total order right now let's get back to
the interviews I just want to see them
getting r with real boxes he's caught
out like Canelo but it's like why would
Canelo take that fight like you know
what I'm saying like Canelo ridiculous
I'm I'm cool with Jake but I I think
that I like him for the sport I just
don't think he'll be able to beat no
Canelo I think Canelo on a do you think
he takes do you think Jake takes boxing
at least serious like he he puts in the
work cuz that's the one thing people say
is like he actually like gives respect
to the sport yeah I think he do I think
that he um do real training camps he got
uh real boxers around him and Jay Leon
love and I think that BJ Flores dude was
a boxer maybe so I think that do take it
serious I just think it it's just
different levels to to it when it come
down to it um tell me about uh in in
terms of what we're two weeks out what
are the things you're doing like on a
daily basis like let's say 5 days out
from the fight like is there anything
you're changing up is there anything
you're like whether it's diet whether
it's regimen are you slowing down a
little bit the last week like nah ain't
nothing really I'm changing up it's the
same routine
um I'mma get my run
in most I probably slow down on uh the
portion size of my food um may go down
some cuz uh we in a weight cut process
but um other than that n I'll be I'm
doing the same thing it's man this it
seemed like it's just another day for me
just another day just another day the
entire fight week on fight day I try to
treat it like it's just another day I'm
curious you're obviously a fan of the
sport what is a fight you want to see
that maybe isn't in your weight class
that you just as a fan you would just
love to see happen a fight that isn't in
my weight class but as a fan I would
love to see Canelo versus Terren that'd
be crazy I would like to see that fight
just because a lot of people think that
bud is not big enough um when I just
watched Canelo with Charlo I seen like a
lot of things Bud could capitalize on so
you saw cuz cuz you know a lot of people
say that like the like charot kind of
like laid down you know what I'm saying
like you saw some things like the chinks
and the armor you were talking about
people want to see with you you did you
see those with Canelo during that fight
I did for sure I seen
um I don't know how like conditioned he
is like it's so it's weird it's like he
start off first four rounds um bombs
away big strong punches then like the
the punches kind of go down a little bit
and he start fighting like spurts then I
see like he throwing like one or two big
shots and um a smart fighter like if you
catch and shoot him when he going that
wide you catch him in between his
punches but um he's a like he's a hell
of a fighter I'm not saying that I'm
just saying far as like somebody like
Bud I think bud can capitalize on a lot
of the things that I seen him doing with
uh TR that'd be crazy oh we all always
talk about like who the greatest of all
time is there's the obvious names we all
know Floyd ol go through who do you
think is the most underrated fighter
ever most underrated fighter ever Andre
Ward okay Andre Ward for sure there no
question about it um underrated fighter
Andre W I don't think he got all the
props that he deserved in the sport of
boxing and I think it got a lot to do
with um social media and all that kind
of stuff being important in our world
and honestly I think that Andre wood was
one of the best fighters that I done
seen lace up a pair of gloves
um have you got to kick it with Tyson at
all um I did his show how was that did
he try to get you to smoke the Toad n he
ain't try to get me to do none of that
but you could tell he was high on the
show be high as [__] he doing like he be
doing some other other worldly [__] yeah
cuz he be talking sometimes and when he
say something he'll forget what he's
saying then he'll come back to it I'm
like man what the hell and then he got
like some crazy opinions but uh I I
crazy opinions like what man he told me
he like uh I mean it's crazy to me it's
probably not crazy to somebody else but
he was like getting comfortable with
losing or something like that like he
explained it the right the right way
like it sounded good on the show but I
still to this day didn't understand what
he meant by uh getting comfortable
losing like how losing is good for you
and all that I mean you know Mike Tyson
has done a lot of therapeutic
psychedelics yeah so he's shed all ego
that it's probably possible for him to
have so you know I get it but he's a
goat though I got I mean he's he's
definitely a goat I love Mike tyon I
love his story I love the way that
uh the the way he came up you could
listen to um how tough he was how
mentally um he got like down and then
came back up and uh I just I just love
mik t i wonder like obviously you have a
long career ahead of you when you see
some of the after boxing stuff that a
guy like Ty and does like people
actually pay to go watch and just shoot
the [__] in Vegas you know he had a
Vegas show for a second and then you see
it fights happening like Floyd will just
go beat the [__] out of some like
scrawny kid in like Dubai for like $30
million yeah like are like once you're
kind of like officially retired like do
you see yourself like doing any any sort
of that [__] like let me go grab 25
million in Dubai and mop up some some
dude's cousin you know or a podcast or
something I would definitely do it just
cuz no like I'm I'm I'm I got too much
experience I got too much knowledge for
somebody that don't know nothing about
boxing so uh ain't no worries ain't no
RIS ain't okay throw me in the ring come
on let's go play around with uh you know
by build sometimes yeah I think that's
like with Floyd I feel like Floyd like
me and my co-host will be talking about
Floyd's fighting this weekend I'm like
what since when hey you know what's
crazy though Floyd still be looking
sharp as ever still look sharp as hell
and he's like a whole ass Grandpa yeah
he be beating young people up in the gym
n Floyd I always wonder if Floyd ever
has to have like a like the grandpa to
like daughter's baby daddy talk with NBA
young boy like I just like one day I
hope someone asks him about that like
what's what's that what's like the
grandpa to you know uh baby daddy talk
like with Floyd and NBA young boy but I
don't know I don't know their
situation know their situation so I I
ain't going to speak on it but who who's
on the under undercard for you uh on on
on on the upcoming fight November 16th
navarat okay navarat they uh what I'm
hearing they building a fight between me
and him uh probably next oh so so he's
so he's fighting before you he better
win he's my co-main he's fighting
somebody that I beat the Robson uh dude
he's fighting him so so this is like an
audition kind of for him they going to
try to put they're going to try to put
him in the ring of him see if he could
get the stopage and then try to use say
oh he he stopped him and I didn't but ah
Styles make fights so it's a lot of
people that Pacquiao stopped that Floyd
didn't stop and that is true got the
ring that is true well listen man the
fights in Vegas uh I'm sure you can
still get tickets you could get the
pay-per-view November 16th shur
Stevenson Edwin deos Santos yes sir
hopefully we get the Haney fight one day
man that's all up to him he and his team
got to be willing to get in a ring with
me make it happen man I want to I would
love it I would love that fight it's got
to happen man the fans want to see it
don't and don't make it happen like like
when we saw Pacquiao and Mayweather and
they were both old man can we just make
sure that you you got to talk to Bill
Haney that's the bill Haney plan the
bill Haney plan is to watch see nobody
wants to see you guys a 50 fight man he
want to see a [__] in my armor so he's
waiting to see any thing before he throw
his son in the is that I that's his dad
yeah his dad I think that they they they
kind of game plan around that like if
you watch uh they'll wait till somebody
have a bad performance and then they'll
fight him go check like the the the
history even with reges reges just for
and he had a bad performance and now
they want to get in the ring with him
trying to protect the bag get in the
ring with
Tio everyone's trying to protect the bag
and boxing man yeah there a bunch of
[__] ass
[__] there you go Shakur Evon man I
appreciate your time brother y I love
boom fire yo we're wrapping up an
interview man of course we want to shout
out to our family at Hardin baby Harden
Las Vegas celebrating their seventh
birthday this month so happy birthday to
harden uh I want to give a shout out to
the whole family over there when you're
in Las Vegas you got to pull up to Hardy
and tell them that the bootleg head
podcast sends you they're going to take
care of you it is the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis in the country all
Under One Roof you walk in and it's just
a VI beautiful butt tenders amazing
smoke just the illst merch you know what
I'm saying and it's right in Las Vegas
right in Sin City so you land in Vegas
you about to go gamble with your boys
you get in that cab you say take me to
harden they're going to know exactly
where to take you all right shout out to
harden go follow him hardine Las Vegas
or go to the website Hardin vegas.com